Hãy dân lịch hàng nàn không chăm 2-6 các đêm vui trời của thủ đô thủ hút đông đạo người dân và dù khác.
Hoa vào nhiên vui chung với người dân hạnh nội, nhiều người nước ngoài hào hứng tận hưởng không khi đón tết dân lịch tại thủ đô.
Hù vực chung tâm hồ hoàn kiếm được chân hoàn lộng lấy thủ đông đạo người dân và dù khác đi dạo chục anh lưu nhiệm.
Không khi đón 5 xàn gập nghiêm vô của người dân và dù khác với những mong ước 1 năm mới, bình ảnh tốt lành, cuộc yêu ki vào.
Thủ đô của các bạn là một thành phố thật năng đậu với nhiều mổ sắc bàn hoa, tự thích các món ăn truyền thống không giản phủ của Hanoi và tất nhiên là sự ấm áp và hiểu khác của các bạn nữa.
Chung nằm mới 2 không 2 sấu nhiều sự khỏe và mấy mắn.
Và chàng chỉ, băng dôn, bà nô áp phích chào đón 5 xe 2 ảnh không 2 mì sấu và những bạn chế trong tạo dài nảo nước chục anh là những hình ảnh dễ bắt đập trên đường phố Hanoi những nghề này.
Bầu khu khi đón tết dân lịch 2 ảnh không 2 mì sấu vui tươi, dọn dàng của người dân thủ đô về ảnh tượng với không ít dù khác.
Hành phố Hanoi hiện đại với không dân mở nhưng dầu bản sắc vàn hóa khiến tôi có cảm giác như ở nhà.
Con người nơi đầy thật thân thiện và hiểu khác, đất nước Việt Nam của các bạn là một điểm đến ăn toàn và nầy xe khu.
Ó sít nị, chúng tôi thường đón 5 mở những bữa tiệc chính bại biển với âm nhạc, bà bè và người thân xung học.
Tất nhiên không thể thiệu phó hoa.
Ó Việt Nam, tôi được biết các bạn cũng tổ chức bản phó hoa chào năm mới, chỉ khác đôi chút là sâu đó các bạn xúc đường đi dạo và chào cho nhau những lời chút tốt đẹp cho năm mới, được đó năm mới ở Việt Nam là một tránh nghiệp đặc biệt.
Không chỉ có em tự vời dù khác quốc tế với khu khi xôi đồng, tất dương lịch Hành hạn không chảm hai mì sấu còn là dịp để nhiều người nước ngoài đang sinh sống học tập và làm việc tại thủ đô hướng về gia đình.
Tất dương lịch dù ở đâu, điều mang ý nghĩa chung vẫn là đo năm mới với nhiều hiểu phọng và cảm xúc tích cửc.
Nằm thí sấu, tôi đón tất dương lịch ở Việt Nam, vợ tôi là người Việt Nam, với nên đầy cũng là quế hương thứ 2 của tôi.
Nằm này, tất dương lịch sẽ được nghĩ bốn ngày, tôi cứ định sẽ được con trải bà tuổi của mình về quế ngoài tất hưởng trọn vẻ kỳ nghe.
Chúc năm mới 2 hồng hại sấu nhiều máy mắn và chẳng gặp nghiệm vui sẽ đến với tất cả chúng ta.
Có thể thấy, hoạt động vui tất dương lịch và trào đón năm mới 2 gàn khu trọng hại mình sấu tại Hà Nội đang diễn ra suy nội, mang đến nhiều trải nghiệm ý nghĩa, khó quyền trong người dân và su khách.